jordan clepper uh of comedy central uh
division of viacom cbs uh he's got an
essay for us reflecting on the events of
january 6. uh you probably know klepper
from his interviews with trump
supporters over the years
he
was at the capitol you can see him there
uh on january 6th uh and so what he's
delivered to us is his opinion uh and
reflections on that day uh and why he
thinks that satire can help all of us
make sense of what happened so take a
look
this week's one-year anniversary of the
events of january 6 presents an
opportunity to reflect on a day that has
been called an insurrection a rebellion
and just a normal tourist visit i'm sure
we all remember our first trip to the
capitol bright-eyed bushy-tailed with a
fistful of zip ties and bear spray the
most photographed crime in modern
history has provided many shades of
interpretation for americans it's our
democracy's dress moment
is it blue is it black is it a deep
state blouse posing as a frock this mass
of people
they broke through the gates here as
someone who was there that day covering
the events for a satirical comedy show i
went looking for absurdity very very
angry people can i ask why you're
carrying a pitchfork and for my sins
they gave it to me iconic representation
of how of what people over time have
done in this country it feels more like
a weapon
you could argue that comedy has no place
in the center of an armed rebellion and
i could argue that when a former improv
comedy teacher needs four bodyguards
to ask citizens who won the election the
normal rules no longer apply
very serious people will tell you this
is no comedy it is a horror but if your
reaction to the events of january 6 was
to be horrified you weren't paying
attention horror presumes surprise and
shock the events of january 6 were
telegraphed for months
we will win this fight or america would
step off into a thousand years of
darkness
let's have trial by combat
so rarely does a confession of intent
come through a loudspeaker
those who act surprised are bad actors
take it from me
take it from me take it from me a bad
actor what i saw that day was tragic it
was frightening and
it was laughable now
it is a mistake to suppose laughter is
the reflex of the unserious george
saunders the great american humorist
said humor is what happens when we're
told the truth quicker and more directly
than we're used to is there a faster way
to show our broken nation than almost
any image from the sixth you can tell
these people really love america by the
number of weapons they brought
to hurt other americans that day i found
myself walking through a real-time dark
comedy
satire as a genre exaggerates our flaws
to expose lunacy now americans don't
need the satirists they've taken to
self-publishing laughter isn't the best
medicine it's the last medicine when
your shock and your awe and your pearl
clutching amounts to nothing you got to
call it as you see it
a joke
yet laughter shouldn't hide the danger
and the urgency laughter is also
cleansing and i can only hope the
post-jovial clear eyes see a country
ready to be serious once more
um well done jordan clapper yeah yeah i
mean i think it's difficult to do what
he did to find the humor and i like what
he said went looking for absurdity
because that's exactly what that was
that day right you found it yeah i know
i mean there's a lot of absurdity a lot
of buffoonery that day the outfits uh
but there's also a lot of danger it's
hard to find the balance between the two
and you can't live in that headspace all
the time i mean we were just there
yesterday marking the anniversary you
need to get out of it and laughter is
one way to kind of remind yourself
you're part of a bigger human family and
i commend comedians that look at the
ridiculousness of some of the pain that
we go through it helps us understand and
heal that's for sure